[Music]
dominic
here we are in our lovely studio for the
friendship onion once again this week
i'm taking my shoes off i'm doing the
same dump now i read online someone
oh just throw them off in a fit of joy
ah that wasn't good
oh you can't leave that there that looks
like some sort of
protest kick it off kick it off where
would it go
just kick it where you went the other
one right ready
he's done it oh lovely wow um
i was reading people um chatting about
our podcast and leaving messages for us
and stuff like that
and someone left me a message to say
because you had taken your shoes off a
few weeks ago and they said
when another human takes their shoes off
in front of another human
it's because they're extremely
comfortable in front of them which is
it's true it's a vulnerable thing to do
isn't it
as horses will also do that their shoes
much more difficult for a horse to
remove a shoe yeah
yeah look at look i've got van gogh
socks on or as they say in the united
states
van gogh they're very nice
thank you spy rule starry starry night
who said
green who sang that you you well just
then but who was the artist
do you want another pope simon no
another question yes
you never give me one well that's a good
point actually i just asked you a
question
that you'll get it from this right he
wrote a
much bigger iconic
hit called american pie
american pie i got myself it to the
level
but the living was sad was a levy
i think is it a lavi is it like a toilet
no
it drove you shave it in the toilet levy
it's got something to do with water
it was dry i think it's is it the wall
that holds in the water
is that not a dam damn you might be
right
if anyone out there knows what a levy is
and why
this songwriter drove his chevy to the
levee and why he was so disappointed
that it was dry
please send an email to the friendship
onion at castmedia.com
you just said all that stuff because
you're delaying because you don't know
the answer i don't do i give you his
initials
yeah which is interesting because you
know me right
d right m same as dominic monahan
er a dog's mother er
dwayne name of it made me a famous
cartoon character don
don don scottish name
mclean
from the northern mcleans now if you
like don mclean who i absolutely do
and you know his iconic song american
pie
and vincent's starry starry night
which is about vincent van gogh he also
sings an amazingly beautiful song called
crossroads which used to make an
ex-girlfriend and i
weep openly could you sing it quietly
and and just into my ear
you know i actually don't really
remember it very well anymore but
do a google not a google search do a
spotify search you can find us on
spotify
um for crossroads by don mclean and you
will weep
but is it about um the the
guitarist robert johnson who sold his
soul to the devil
at the crossroads it's not about that
from what i remember it seems to be
about
two which is probably why my ex and i
used to cry about
two lovers right at a crossroads in
their life where one of them says
i'm going this way one of them's saying
i'm going to mcdonald's and the other
one's saying
i've got a burger king that's a metaphor
they're not actually getting different
burgers it's like i'm
i'm going to be a scientist great
i'm going to be a fisherman well we can
still be together
can we because i'm on boats for like six
months
in the deep i'm a scientist i'll
discover how we can be together
really yeah okay great well maybe we can
continue on in this do you remember a
soap opera called crossroads
it's a bit young for it but i do
remember it there was a character called
benny in it
oh yeah and he wore a very little hat a
beanie
and if anybody wore a beanie hat you
called him benny
right what was crossroads about what was
like coronation street's about that
street and eastenders is about that
square
yeah it was about a hotel called
crossroads
i'm sure that's probably what don mclean
was singing about
yeah good point also this week since i'm
they call me mr generous head i've
brought for you
a gift a feather wow
i presented together from a peacock yeah
my god that's very delicate hang up
there you go now it's very different
from the bottom
i thought you'd like that that's lovely
isn't that lovely where did you find a
peacock
it was just like walking around a
peacock yeah
and i scared it and it dropped some of
its feathers peacock male or female
pickup
that would be a meal because he has his
feathers to
impress the ladies and also at times
maybe
say to a large predator i'm way bigger
than you think i am
by showing you the size of my ruffle
yeah it doesn't smell
i just thought i'd smell i like to smell
things yeah do you
yeah yeah i think if someone hands me
something i'll smell it
really yeah okay worth keeping in mind
well should we get to some questions uh
i still get more questions about the
feather oh okay yeah where did you find
it
well actually my friend carrie who you
know well
was celebrating an early birthday this
week i went down to oceanside and we
were trying to think of some sort of
theme of sorts that we could engineer
the night around and my friend fleur and
i said
why don't we dress carry up like a
peacock
in those colors we can put red okay
and then everyone else can paint their
nails lovely
colored so that also meant the rest of
the party didn't necessarily need to go
all bells and whistles and
carrie could be the focus and we ended
up with probably
40 peacock feathers that we didn't use
and i looked at one and i thought
billy would love that i love that i'll
take that home and i'll place it
somewhere it's a shame you don't have a
cat
because i get the impression cats would
love that don't think your dog would be
into that i'll see what bobby johnson
thinks of it i'll wave it in front of
his face he'll just be like
we'll see what he does we'll see i
actually that's not the first time
someone's given me a feather as a
present go on
it was my birthday down in new zealand
one time
and we were having a little what we call
do
a little party around at my place
and uh you came along and a few friends
came along and
and viggo came and he said i have a
present for you
and i know that viggo is quite a rich
man
yeah so i was a you know a generous man
i thought maybe a range rover or
a small small house at the beach and he
he gave me a lovely feather do you know
what bird it come from
uh no but it was lovely
and uh i still have that feather this
day lovely
was that a do is that what you're saying
oh no i do
sorry i do is a scottish word for a
pigeon
it certainly wasn't right yes wow
i do you mean ah do or the actual
animal is called oh there's an ado no oh
i do yeah do you you may see someone
do you keep do's oh right i do keep do's
i keep a few do's right
how do you feel about pigeons i like
them my brother's not a fan
why he's one of those you know those
gang of people he calls them uh
rats with feathers a gang of people well
there are still like pigeons yeah
there's a group of people out there that
are just like
any any kind of town-based animal right
they see
okay you know they're like well
squirrels rats with fairy tales
pigeons rats with feathers this thing
it's all rats with something but then if
my brother and i are maybe walking in a
in a wood or one of my favorite english
words are cops mmm
nice c-o-p-s-e uh and you hear a wood
pigeon
so now that was was that a pigeon doing
it now yeah
right not like that um he'll go oh
lovely wood pigeon you can hear those
wood pigeons
yeah but if you brought that over to
yeah manchester in the house
rats with feathers oh emails and real
mails fastest
now should we get to some questions
let's do some questions let's
see uh
some lovely written in questions here if
you guys have any questions please send
them the friendship onion oh no it's
just friendship onion at castmedia.com
it was for a little bit there
the and we dropped the ver no no it was
friendship and now it's the
that's what i mean so the modern one the
modern email for our show
is the friendship onion at castmedia.com
with a kicking k
here's a question from gigi oh from new
brighton i don't know where new brighton
is
i don't know gigi says i'm a games
design student and therefore have a
string interest in gaming but i'm
guessing
strong right
think strong yeah yeah how do you feel
about the idea of
video games as an art form are there any
video games you two
feel have a strong artistic voice or
merit
now you're more of the gaming guy than
me to be honest um
i if anyone brought an atari
to anywhere i will be anyone
i had to burp there i get so excited i
will beat
anyone at any game on an old
atari remember he's saying that back in
new zealand because elijah was like a
big gamer guy
and you had said if you can get hold of
an atari i will beat you hands down
and i have proven that when there is
retro knights
in like a pub or something and there's
an atari
i can play any game on an atari but if
you could pick one what would you i'd
pick gallagher but what would you pick
i well there's a few games at back in
the day
when adventure came out i love that game
yeah adventures
i love that but once you play that a few
times it's sort of you know it's kind of
repetitive
but uh if i had to pick any game
from an atari i'm killing time here from
an atta
a defender oh defender is that the one
we have to put a little dot where the
explosion's coming down
no but i love that i know yeah it's when
you have a little ship and you can go
forward and back and then you have to go
through the mountains and
drop bombs as well as fire machine guns
yeah
nice does it make that nice no that was
a wood pigeon
nice don't think it's interesting when
someone says back in the day like you
just said back in the day there
yeah when you're saying back in the day
are you always
picturing a tuesday or a wednesday i
don't know but it's one of my favorite
scenes i like saying that too but i
never picture a weekend like if someone
says
ah back in the day i was really big on
space invaders i never think oh he means
a saturday or a sunday i always think
he means a tuesday or a wednesday back
way back right okay i don't think of a
day oh okay
we'll drop that then let's answer this
question
you answer it because you're a video
game guy well a little bit more than you
speak man there's some
i think i was talking to john about this
a couple of weeks ago
uh i think it was john the last of us
game made me cry i was playing it
and no spoilers but something happened
in the game where i watched the
piece of cut footage and then it asked
me at that point to play on with the
game and had to pause it and
get myself together because i was
overcoming the motion that is very rare
in a game that's great amazing that's
amazing yeah but then other stuff like
during covid i picked up um planet zoo
which is a zoo oh you can't tell your
story in a second
it's a zoo simulator where you start
with
40 000 fictional dollars and you have to
you know what you're gonna do no
no i'm just laughing at you doing this
soothing because i just remembered when
you were playing it brilliant
and you were asking your your instagram
people it's brilliant to help you
and it was always silly things like why
is nobody coming to see my penguins yeah
and they would say well you don't have a
pass yeah
i'd built i built an enclosure and i
needed my zookeeper to go in there and
drop off a new tortoise that i bought
but my zookeeper wouldn't access the
uh the enclosure which meant all my tour
choices were dying because there's no
food in there and my friends
were friends online that i didn't know
but sweet people were like
you need to build a path and then
so that that what you're supposed to do
as as we know in these simulators is
start small and
build yeah so you start with an
enclosure of tour choices maybe an
enclosure of ostriches
right have them be happy and brief yeah
and then you sell those and then with
the profits
you do build it slowly this podcast is
sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
i know a lot of people have been having
problems since the covered times of hit
is done
yeah people have been spending a lot of
time on their own and sometimes that can
cause you know
a little bit of mental health issues so
better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist and the great
thing is you can start communicating in
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counselling done securely online
and there is a broad range of expertise
available
which not might not be locally available
in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide
you can log into your account at any
time and send a message to your
counselor
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today so visit
betterhelp.com onion that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counsellors in all
50 states special offer for the
friendship onion listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
i tell you something that me and dom
love
a service called one dream it's
incredible
full of mind-blowing facts that you can
bring into your everyday life
now if you're familiar with the great
courses plus
then you already know one dream it's the
same great service but with so
much more with one dream you can explore
thousands of hours of fascinating videos
and audio
content documentaries tutorials
travel logs and so much more find the
answers to the questions that you've
always been wondering about
like i've just been lately looking at
the crimes of the century
a selective history of infamy really
really interesting and some of it is
actually a little
scary like the um murderous
maids anyway we
know you're going to love one room as
much as we do
use our special url so that they know
that we
sent you go now to onedrive.com
onion and for a limited time sign up
and you'll get a free month trial of
unlimited access that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash onion again one dream dot
com
slash onion sign up today
you need to tell your story about the
simulator that you built
that you ruined overnight and your son
was super disappointed oh that you can
have superheroes in it
some city we got really that's a good
game actually
right that's the same thing yeah you
start off you build a couple of
houses and then you know i'll sort of
tell you these people in these houses
want to go to work you know so you
slowly build the city and we built it
over like weeks
and it was big and it was we'd went to i
mean
we now had like solar power and we had
um
everything you would want in a city we
were near the water and
fairies were coming in and people were
coming in and and
uh hot air balloons we had the globe
theater was there
we had um a stadium where we used to
have big shows and that brought in a lot
of money
but then for some reason i said a lot of
people are coming to this town
we need we need a bigger a bus service
so i built all these bus stations and
all these buses
but nobody was taking the buses down and
it was too expensive
so he saved money i had to switch off
the the police
but then there was a lot of crime
because i'd opened a lot of casinos
and now when my son was out i would i
would run this thing
and i was like i can fix this i can fix
it i'm the mayor of this town
and that totally destroyed it but then
didn't you also say
that crime had like got out of control
oh it was crazy
and i could only switch them on for an
hour that's all i could afford
but then i said jokingly to you i was
like oh they should have like a
a batman type character that you can put
into the city to take care of stuff and
you said they did
i think that but we weren't
and then pretty much over a couple of
nights you were like i've
messed up i destroyed that he's very
good at saying just do this just do that
and uh i tried to do everything at once
ridiculous
meticulous so that's a good game so
that's i mean those simulated games are
great and i mean you know
uncharted and skyrim amazing
um and obviously league of legends we
play has some beautiful designs
yeah great characters on that what do
you want do you want to answer this
question
okay there's some alliteration here mike
from massachusetts
massachusetts i always feel like
massachusetts sounds like a train
how do you say that massachusetts and
the
lights
yeah as you know the grey havens
is a sort of elven paradise not
dissimilar
to the idea of heaven very good yeah
the question i would like to pose to
both of you
if the grey havens existed for us in
2021
who would be the one person you would
bring with
you i suppose and what would your
version
of the undying lands look like
so yeah the the elven paradise
of the undying lands is real
you can only take one person dom and
what would your undying lands look like
well i've not seen my mum for like
almost two years
and my dad maureen momo um
but uh i think you're allowed to call
your parents one person
oh great that's i've changed the rules
from mike here thanks bills i've not
seen my parents for a couple of years
oh and uh i don't know if i've ever
mentioned this to you
but i'd love to sit with your dad and
open a nice fresh tin of condensed milk
he got a tin of condensed milk last
minute
last week i showed you that photo right
today two teaspoons
and just set watch your football oh i'd
love it before
that guaranteed if you ever make it
back over to england or maybe spain
where my parents live when we're all
together
guaranteed at some point my dad would be
like billy i've got it
i've got it i would love that anyway
i've not seen my parents for a couple of
years
i miss them dearly and in terms of uh
hanging out i mean you know my mom and
dad are both fantastic
uh cooks and it would be great to just
sit around and have a long lazy
dinner lovely and maybe uh
a lovely lemon drizzle cake because my
dad makes a fantastic lemon drizzle cake
and that would be your undying lens yeah
i think so
a sort of nice living room yeah
fireplace
fireplace sure maybe a film afterwards
maybe my brother and his son and his
wife
well yeah i guess just my parents then
yeah that would be lovely i'm i'm
i definitely miss them now how about you
right
well if you don't put your wife in major
trouble oh
well obviously it would be my my wife
and child
yeah yeah okay yeah i had one yet oh
yeah yeah
and um my version of the undying lands
well here's the thing here's a great
thing about um
having kids is you you see the world
anew again as you as you start to get
older
and you get this new person this new
human who's
seeing everything for the first time so
lately
jack's thing has been surfing
and it's got me way back into surfing
again and getting in the ocean and
enjoying the waves and just you know
being out there is just
lovely and i've forgotten how much i
love it so at the moment
the undying lands for me would be there
with my wife
and child and just a nice rolling wave
that we can just enjoy there now your
wife doesn't surf
no but let me paint a picture for you
here
you inject out surfing waves are perfect
yeah they're coming in
nice little sets but nice little breaks
between the
yep you give ali a little wave she's on
the beach she's reading she's gonna see
it
and you go ten minutes ten minutes we're
coming in she goes oh great
and then you're not concentrating on
what ally's doing because
you're surfing a jet yeah but without
you knowing yeah
she calls over a a lovely young waiter
and she says
uh can we get a couple of nice drinks
from
my husband and my son coming in and
maybe a couple of little
you know just something some hummus or
some black olives or something and as
you come up from the beach
spent you've had the sun on your head
all day you need a drink
ali says just sit down yeah here have
this
wait finish the sentence for me have
this margarita have this margarita yeah
here's some black olives here's some
hummus
jack i've got you a a horse called brian
perfect perfect the undying lands is
wonderful
yeah thanks for the question thank you
mike from massachusetts
and now very exciting because we've got
a riddle
and you and i love riddles we did ask
people to send riddles
yeah to the friendship onion at
castmedia.com please so this one comes
from
carrie ann york or is it carrie anne in
york we don't know i think it's carrion
york
okay now here's the riddle the rich
want it the poor
have it it is bigger than god
if you eat it you will die
never heard that riddle before i have
never heard that either let's think
about that
well we can work this out well the rich
want do the rich want cash no they've
got cash they've got cash they want
power the rich want power the poor
don't have power generally no unless
well
the poor time
time the rich want time the people have
time well they don't have any more than
the right i suppose what about it's
bigger than god
okay have it what about nothing
the rich want it nothing the poor have
it nothing
it's bigger than god nothing is bigger
than if you're here you'll die nothing
did you not know i didn't know it that
we did it in real time
john john i j is it right that is right
i genuinely you are a proverbial
genius you got me there because you were
like what did you say before
free no time time and i thought when you
said time i was like i don't think it's
time but it's a big
concept yeah wow that's a great one
carrie annual fantastic and dom
got it i got it brilliant yeah yeah i
was stoked by that
i was stoked oh here we go bills you
want to read out this buttery
story yeah we love buttery stories
thanks it's from angela
we're not sure where she's from but we
know it's from angela so angela
if you recognize this butter story this
is your one thing no i haven't read this
dom wait to hear here we go angela says
back in college while majoring in
art education i had a goal to create
100 portraits to perfect
my craft which i usually posted on
facebook upon their completion
one of these portraits was a friend of
mine sculpted out of
you've guessed it butter wow
i gifted it to her and she thought it
was hilarious
i even sat in the freezer for several
months now
fast forward a bit a guy who knew
us both asked me out on a first date we
did frisbee golf
which i was terrible at but we had a
great time he asked me out again
and said last time we did something that
i was really good at
so this time i thought we'd do something
that you're really good at
we're going to do some butter sculpting
we had a wonderful and comical time
beautiful
i am happy to say that last year that
man and i
celebrated our eighth wedding
anniversary
as well as the birth of our third child
and first daughter
we named her rose and we often refer to
her
as a little rosy cotton well that is
absolutely lovely isn't that good see
butter can bring people together i love
butter yeah
how about that richard taylor story last
week about the fact that he used to
fashion things out of margaery
and now we're talking about butter again
he would fashion it
give it to the restaurant so that he
could get a meal
he was so skinned ain't no money amazing
and there's another great butter story
butter
the great giver now we've had a couple
of lovely comments on our youtube
channel as well the friendship onion
over uh youtube you can watch us oh and
people have asked me this a few times so
let's just clarify
the audio drop of the podcast
is usually about two hours
ahead of the youtube drone so lots of
people will say
hey i saw that the podcast is ready to
listen
when is it ready on youtube it's usually
within a couple of hours you'll get it
on youtube which is weird isn't it
because
you would think the speed of light is
faster than the speed of sound
good point but yeah it's slower in real
life
for some reason really yes done
summer is winding down and so is its
carefree nature
ease back into reality by seeing how
much you could save
on home and auto insurance that's right
dom get your
adult back to school less sorted haircut
organize your office find a better deal
on your home and auto insurance
i tell you what policy genius can help
you with the last one
it's never a bad time to find ways to
bundle your home and auto insurance and
save on coverage
with policy genius so if your home and
auto policies are almost up for renewal
let policy genius look for a lower rate
for you they saved customers an average
of 1
250 a year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance they've
saved new customers an average of
435 dollars per year on auto insurance
they've also saved new customers an
average of 350 dollars per year on home
insurance
their team will handle the paperwork to
set up your new policy or switch over
your current one
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com answer a few questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius takes it from there
fantastic so head to policygenius.com
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
now billy of an evening in los angeles
in fact last weekend
we sat around glass of wine we're
reading a play
the sun's going down we're chatting with
your wife the dog's running around the
garden and we think
what we missing here and you said to me
i'll tell you what we're missing i'll
tell you what we're missing missing a
fire pit and you got out
the bonfire fire pit from solo stove
and lit it and wasn't it lovely lovely
it absolutely changes
an evening and i really mean that this
solo stove
so easy light you get the fire going
easy
it doesn't have all the smoke of a
normal fire pit it's got some sort of
crazy technique of getting rid of the
smoke that works brilliant
and i think just having a fire pit in
the evening just gives the evening a
focus
it just solo stove
creates story worthy moments without the
fireside
fumes i mean no one forgets the time at
summer camp the friendships activities
and most importantly
the s'mores oh that's absolutely true
stainless steel construction designed to
regulate the airflow and burn
more efficiently with the design of solo
stove
just makes it really fun to sit next to
because like you said you've not got
smoke kicking back towards you lovely
no one needs a reason to gather round
the fire
but solo stove just took away any reason
not to and now you can get 10 off when
you use the promo code
onion at checkout just go to
solostove.com
and remember you get 10 off when you use
the promo code
onion leave your reviews and maybe we'll
read them out on
the show in fact we're going to read
this one out right now from jamie n
thank you jimmy hello jbm who says this
is just pure joy
hopefully he's talking about the podcast
you are given a front-row seat to an
amazing friendship
wrapped in a fandom wrapped in a string
theory
well that's true well that is very nice
thank you very much
in terms of guess we were talking about
stephen colbert there's a strong
chance that we might also have a string
theorist come in sometime
soon and really bender melons
i can't wait um i think i i know that
it sounds weird and unusual but i really
think at some point i will find the
answer to everything
do you think that the reason why you're
so
intrigued and obsessed with string
theory is that thing where
that almost like the feeling of sand
slipping through your hands the
closer you get to understanding it the
less you know is it that intriguing
thing with your brain where you're like
i'm almost there i lost it
there is that and i also love the idea
uh like we were talking about before
that you know
things that seem really important like
you know a painful knee or something
but that's actually not reality right
the reality
is the reality
is actually there's the strings in money
they don't even know that the knee is
not working right
you know the reality is there is no dom
monahan
you don't exist all right
the actual reality if we could just get
our heads around it but wait let me ask
you wait
you might not be the right person to ask
i am maybe the
string theorist who's coming in might be
at one point your knee was fine a few
months back yeah
or a couple months back your knee was
fine now that your knee is slightly
compromised
has that also compromised all of the
other
strings in the galaxy type thing or just
the strings in your knee
well here's the thing because i think if
we
understand string theory correctly then
there is no knee you're right there is
no spoon
a great moment in the matrix right there
exactly
how do you bend the spoon and the little
kid says well the thing to keep in mind
is there is no spoon
you see
uh lovely stuff thank you jamie m
thank you do you want to read this uh
one here bill
kobo and the beat that sounds like a
great band that i would go and see on a
saturday afternoon somewhere
kobo and the beat says there are some
podcasts where you feel like an hour's a
bit much
well i guarantee you want the friendship
onion to be three hours
i love it so much dom and billy are two
of my favorite people ever
i love this show i feel i feel weird
reading out nice things about ourselves
yeah
but i think it's nice to tell kobo on
the beat that we've read it and we
we want to thank them it's very
unbritish isn't it to kind of blow our
own trumpet
but we'll do it every every so often um
thank you for that and also in terms of
a longer podcast i know you and i had
spoken at some point about
what we might do for a christmas episode
and one of the ideas for a christmas
episode
which i love by the way is that you and
i get a little
inebriated on some late night and doing
episode
and i think if we do a sherry episode
instead of it being an hour it may turn
into
two and a half hours it may turn into a
day in a week
a day in a week could you pass me the
candied walnuts and the fermented cheese
i'd like to see john with a couple of
drinks in the mic oh i bet john our
producer
crystal skinful pressing all the wrong
buttons we saw him uh a couple of days
after
a bachelor weekend and he looked
absolutely dreadful he looked he looked
ten years older like he'd been in fights
with like a gang of cats in an alleyway
kicked by a horse that hadn't removed
their shoes
billy and dom eat the world
my dearest dominic william our favorite
part
of the show especially when we're hungry
and and it's something that i've tried
before and i can almost say 100
that you have as well oh yeah we both
grew up with these really didn't we but
this was sent to us by
chris mork we've got your email here
chris
from kinkinete cincinnati
thank you bills oh ohio
ohio who says hello chris this package
is for billy and dom
at the french bunion in the recent show
uh
joe pesci episode five in the video they
discuss
a snack called skips which we could they
could not find in the united states i
live
near a large grocery store an
international market called jungle gyms
which just happened to have skips i
thought i would surprise the boys
with a taste of home thank you inside
there's a bunch of bags of skits and a
little note about finding the snack for
them
please leave the note with a snacks for
them to read maybe they could use it on
a portion of the show that they call
billy and dom eat the world and that is
from chris
so if you guys can safely
send us stuff that we might use please
do so that's the sound of skips in the
packet
now let's talk about skips bills this is
uh
a kind of crisp or chip
like treat eaten by
i think people of all ages little kids
love skips because they've got quite a
gentle
taste haven't they well it's a prawn
cocktail isn't it what is it
they call it a prawn cocktail flavor now
do you mind if i open these these do
get your olfactory system going
give them a sniff get you get your nose
in there as well i
said already today i like to sniff
things yeah
that's no that's good it's put it's got
as punched
fishy yeah pungent's a great word for
that that's uh
it's um it's like the back of a chip
shop so it is yeah yeah
or like you know when you're um you go
in a little holiday in the uk
and and there's a little uh van that
sells
shrimp
i mean to be honest there's a slight
undertone
of piss are you picking up on piss
no i'm not getting that hold on give it
another shake it about i'm getting
pissed you're in you're right
no wow you've really got your nose
surprised you don't bring one out with
you on the end of it i'm not i'm not
getting pissed there at all
okay no piss for you that's good well
let me read some of this stuff
now they're shaped we'll show you
shaped like a little flower you see and
it and it says here why the shape like a
flower
skips twitter says we've done some
digging around and found out the
following the shape of skips was
developed in japan
almost 50 years ago rather than a flower
we think it was designed to look like
the shell
as a backdrop to the prawn flavor yeah i
could see that a seashell
yeah i can see that yeah and um skips uh
were launched in the united kingdom and
ireland
in 1974 in the prawn cocktail flavor now
you and i
grew up with kp skips
but these are made by an irish company
called potatoes
and you know why they're called potatoes
go on uh
because and i've lost this
but someday tried to say
wait a minute oh yeah there we go yeah
started in 1954
the tato factory in dublin the original
factory was opened by the founder
joe spud murphy it was a time when most
chris came from the uk and were
unflavored
uh no it doesn't tell you why but he's
got spud
spud no but no no no no hold on john's
going to save me here
because there was a thing up we said to
john look we're not going to talk about
tato too much we're talking about skips
and they get rid of the thing that told
you why it's called title
but it was basically a kid i can't
remember who it was it's probably joel
murphy's son
yeah and he couldn't see potato
so he said potato potato potato
like that and he and then joe spud
murphy
probably said that's a great name for a
factory
that makes crisps well columns the
potatoes potatoes
my i think anyone whose favorite flavor
of crisp or chip as they're known in the
united states
is just plain you know like ready sword
i think there's something wrong with you
what if you're going to dip it in
something like a like a salsa would you
want it plain then
maybe even then even then i'd want
jalapeno because then got that spice and
this stuff like that
i can't think of a situation where
ready salted or plain crisps is a good
choice for me can you try them no i'm
just going to try
one could you do the same please yeah
and they
melt onto your tongue don't they
actually you're ready about skips
fizzy flat is busy you're maxless
yeah they create quite a lot of um
action in the salivary glands yeah and
you don't need your teeth
if you press your tongue against the top
of your mouth yeah
you can crush it they're gone if you've
had like
wisdom tooth surgery and they said to
you just for the next couple days
eat yogurts and maybe soup you could
also invest in a bag of
skips i used to eat these at the cinema
a lot
sat in the back row trying to like kiss
girls and stuff so it reminds me of like
try kiss girls and stuff isn't it that's
funny when when it's prawn [ __ ] i
wouldn't eat prong cocktail and then try
and kiss someone
know what i'm going to do this thing
i've never had any success with women
back in the day
what i'm going to do now is get a lot of
them
because i've tried them with singular
now i'm going to try this which i'm
going to estimate
is nine ready number
nine that's a lot
billy tried to break the world record of
putting marshmallows in his mouth and he
almost died
how was that that was brilliant how many
marshmallows did you get in your mouth
ish do you remember 11. and did you
do big ones yeah big one but i heard
though that it's very dangerous
because if you suck and you get a
you get a full-sized marshmallow in your
throat
you could die you'd have to do that
thing that's in every medical drama
tracheotomy will you open up somebody's
throat and put a straw in there i'd love
to open up your throat and put a straw
in there
that would be great you probably find a
skip in there right now
dom wait go but wait let me just finish
the other thing with marshmallows is
depending on how much moisture they've
been exposed to they swell don't they
yeah well that's the truth all the way
down your throat
yeah like a sponge you were dancing with
death there
dumb take a big handful of them really
do this for me okay
i'll do it i'll do it because i i feel
as though
that's the way you eat them at least
nine yeah your wife loves skips doesn't
she
she loves them i went to one of the um
british shops a while back and managed
to find
a bag of skips and she was delighted
yeah
what
punch it first i mean it's a lot
when you get a lot of them it's quite a
lot of salt
it's a lot so i have to say i'm still
chasing the dragon
for you to do that thing that you did
with the jardin era
the first time you had it it's one of my
favorite moments in the show
you get the pizza you're struggling we
go right i'll just take a big bite of
that and you put it in your mouth and
you go
oh oh dumb oh like completely
overwhelmed with how happy you were oh
dumb
oh ah well at one point we got but we're
not quite there yet with the skips are
we done
i went away for a trip there mexico and
when i came back
the first thing that me and the family
got was a pizza
and we got a big jar of this yard and
era out of the cupboard
and i covered it in it that's one of the
greatest finds
that the friendship onion has found yet
but i would say
that scripps isn't far behind because
that's a delicious thing
give us another fact
scripts were first launched in 1974
under the description
shrimp cocktail flavor but this was not
persuading enough
so they changed the name to skips
so i guess skip has some of the letters
that also are included in the word
shrimp
i don't know where the cake comes oh
cocktail
cocktail right what what do you think s
for shrimp right
pay for the bit of cocktail and then ips
oops sort of bees what did you say the
air says
shrimp shrimp cocktail inside people's
stomachs
you're a genius isn't it you're a genius
and look the thing about the names just
popped up and i was right
joe murphy's son couldn't pronounce
potato
so he said tato and it became a very
clever way
of marketing in the marketing camp is
there a word
that you still struggle with as a
grown-up
as a grown-up scottish person it's
almost impossible
for a scottish person to say a purple
burglar
alarm a purple burglar
just can't you guys know what billy is
trying to say is purple
burglar alarm absolutely input if you're
from scotland
or if you can do a scottish accent put
it on just now and try and say
a purple burger alarm wow yeah that is
quite
very difficult the other thing that i've
noticed with your
wife and you is that because
of the dramatic difference between
saying
water in scotland and water in the
united states
you guys will just full-on adopt an
american accent when you say what you so
you'll be like um
hi could i get water
you will say like that won't you water
water
because if someone in a restaurant says
you know would you like anything to
drink
and i'll say i'll just have some water
please they go what is that
and i'm like and then i think
i mean you know you ask me if i want a
drink what do you think
i might be seeing yeah it's got to be
close it's got to be something like it
you know
glass of water yeah can i have a glass
of water please
john's laughing and he said and he's
makes someone
hey i'm going to finish these skeptics
in one film oh
this is a good sign this is going to get
a top-class score then we should do the
score
oh don't let him swell in your throat
bills oh god
they're going all over the place to the
state of here
i wasn't expecting the dust oh yeah the
skip dust at the bottom i used to love
i still and you'd always have that kid
at school wouldn't you who would
pulverize them into a powder and eat
them at break time and they'd have them
around the mouth and be like i'll clean
that up oh you had a friend who um
if you if they had a packet of skips and
you said oh can i have one
they would go like that with their hand
so they'd only leave like one skip above
their fingertips
i became one of the major kind of
turning points with my
best mate tom and i back in the day was
all right so i basically i arrived at st
winifred school that's saying grandma we
love you you can't believe that i
arrived at saint winnipeg school in the
very last year the graduating year for
everyone so they've been there for
six years or so and i came in in the
last year so you know had to make
friends quite quickly and one of the
maze
ways that i made friends very quickly
not sure why
i did it but i did do it was it was
break time
and someone had dropped a jelly baby on
the floor but a while back
it was like full of dirt and stuff
and we were looking at it and tom went i
bet no one will eat that
and i picked up an eight and tom was
like you i love you
you're a good friend we're mates now
all right scores scores on the doors
flavor
flavor flavor well it's prone cocktail
they say
and uh is it shrimp cocktail is it
prunky i mean is shrimp and prawn the
same thing i think i feel like it's an
interchangeable word
is it i think so right i would say prong
cocktail
it's a fantastic flavor tom it it's a
great flavor it's subtle though
it's so subtle it's salty
it feels nice on your tongue it's got a
nice
mouth feeling for me i'm go
i mean taste i'm gonna have to give it a
9.2 wow
good tasting crisp it's nice it's a
little too subtle for me in terms of
what i'm looking for out of a crisp but
i enjoyed it i'm giving it
a 7.1 that's all right yeah
it's not great but hey aesthetics
aesthetic the look of it of the bag and
the chip
we can't even look at the chip because
we've at the moment no i've still got
one hang on
hold on i'll hold it up so we can have a
look
describe it to us as much as you can
well the crisp or the chip itself
that's a bad that's a bad example
because that one's slightly messed up
it's basically like the the excuse me
the face of a flower isn't it
like a daisy or a it is but it's got
it's a
it's got veins on it like shrimps
you know like shrimps have those little
veins yeah it's quite pretty
um and also the bag yellow inviting very
food inviting
i think you don't often see crisps with
that delicate design got its own look
hasn't it
yeah so i'm going to give it a strong
9.5 for
that is good well that's good attention
i'll give it an 8.5
okay i'll let you see it a little bigger
use usefulness how useful is a skip
what else would you do with it like say
you had friends coming around
for dinner and all you had skips
skips a loaf of bread a jar of
jardinera and some vanilla ice cream
i i was struggling with usefulness
aren't we really i mean it's a bag of
crisps
did anybody in your family or in your um
circle eat a sandwich and crisps oh i
will
you will still absolutely i love crisps
in a sandwich
salt vinegar or jalapeno chips at the
top of the list
but a lovely crunchy crisp in a sandwich
it also
stops the moist parts of the sandwich
from compromising the bread
well hold on because
explain to me your
number one top sandwich with crisps in
it
oh man well i like a granary
loaf okay so you've got some seeds it's
a brown bread maybe you've got some
you know poppy seeds or caraway seeds or
whatever sesame seeds in there
butter mature english or irish cheddar
or there's some cheese on there but it
has to be
mature you know i'm not messing around i
want the type of cheese to be like
a bit strong yeah rocket
which is a type of spinach you're
putting some veg
you're putting a spinach thing on yeah a
spinach thing on there
right on the other side of the bread
marmite
there's a lot going on here thinly
very thinly sliced green apple
in that sandwich i know wait but because
that
green apple is moist if you put that
next to the bread it's going to make the
bread all softer than you want a layer
of either jalapeno or salt vinegar crisp
in between the green apple and the bread
so the salt and vinegar green apple
marmite rocket
right mature english cheddar the mature
is this not getting a bit
tart oh it's tart but i like you want
the tart
i want my favorite sandwiches are the
ones that you take a bite
and you go i need a minute like with
those some of the crisps that you know i
like i like to have a couple of them and
then put them down and go wow that's
quite intense
okay yeah that's interesting thank you
tom yeah you're welcome
is it hard to get marmite here it's
harder
because i bought you some did you and i
forgot to bring it oh well it's
definitely harder
i saw and i was at a kind of british
store
and i saw mermaid and i thought okay
because i don't eat it
you don't but i thought dom likes it and
i don't know if he's got a place where
he goes
nowhere near me but sometimes when i
come down to see you in the family i'll
zip by the british shop and buy some we
will do
billion dollar meet in the world with
marmite at some point because it is
just an absolute staple isn't it well
next time you come skip
next time you're down i've got a little
jar for you thanks bills do you want to
tell us your favorite sandwich or do you
want to bank that for another time i'll
bang that for an hour
okay we'll bang it for another time so
oh it's a usefulness
can you think of anything else you would
do with skips i mean even if you were
making
like a pie or something like
a like a shrimp pie like a fish pie
you're not going to sprinkle would you
crush
skeptics on and also like you said in a
sandwich you want a crisp that slightly
holds together you put this in a
sandwich it's going to disappear so
you're basically just
eating it as a skip yeah shrimp
cocktail in people's stomachs yeah i
think usefulness for me it's a one
it's a 1.3 for me okay well that was
skips
you guys
[Music]
well that was fantastic and now we are
going to listen to an amazing piece of
music
from sarah vernier
in linden virginia and the song is
called i'm probably going to get this
wrong it looks like it's icelandic
the song is called
freya it is icelandic oh
hang on the song is called think about
things from a band called
who are icelandic to find out whether or
not
this song is funky for you
well dominic that took me an absolute
road trip that was amazing let me ask
you this as a musician that very kind of
classic thing that you hear with
bassists where they kind of don't
don't don't don't like slapping are they
are they kind of hitting hammering on
them that's
basically what they're doing they're
making it bounce but
that's the boom and then that's when
they pull it
boom it's amazing yeah it's
brilliant i liked it and it was weird
was it because it started in a certain
place
and then at one point all the music
sucked me down into a hole did you feel
that yeah yeah and then it came back out
oh
funky like oh imagine being in a club
and that kicks in you'd absolutely love
it i would love it dom
i'd like to be in a roller skating disco
when that came on nice do you know what
i would do that at that point
at that point i would i would i'd put my
legs a kimbo
and i'd go around sideways like crap
i can just picture it right now and also
for you guys out there we've
we've created a spotify list yeah
of songs featured on the friendship
onion and this song
will show up on that spotify list so
come find us at the friendship onion
and uh you can listen to our playlist i
i really liked it it was funky for me
dom it was
it was early 80s weird
synth funky for me i'm going to give it
a
can i give it a mark right now it's not
a mark is it it's a band
i know a person please please do i'm
going to give it early 80s prince
1999. that's funky
that was really funky it was funky for
me too there's no question you can't
argue with the funk there
i'm gonna say duran duran funk
oh lovely pretty funky ten points for
the bass player's name
of jordan durant yeah
who didn't mean slapping it occasionally
i bet he didn't um
was it roger taylor very close john
taylor yeah
roger taylor was roger taylor in queen
was he the champion
he's a drummer from queen who's the bass
player from queen
wait a minute wait a minute oh do you
remember in the movie brian may
brian may freddie and freddie says to
him at one point
i don't even know what you do
no john deacon ah john deacon never mind
well listen guys if you have a song that
you'd like us to listen to
please send in the suggestion and who
knows maybe maybe we'll feature on the
show and maybe we'll put it
in our spotify playlist thank you sarah
fernier i like that i'll check that song
out on the way home
i loved it too uh maybe i'll just do it
on the way home and speaking of which we
have to bounce so we'll see you all
next week don't forget to send all your
messages at
the friendship onion at catsmedia.com
and also your
voice things to speakpipe.com forward
slash the friendship onion
rate review subscribers and we will see
you in a week
see you next week toodles